welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
my name is eric trexler i am the host of
the show but today i am joined by a very
special temporary guest co-host and his
name is greg knuckles greg how are you
doing doing well how are you
i am doing just fine and i'd like to
kick off the show here
by thanking everyone who supported the
mass black friday sale last time we had
a podcast episode we were talking about
that sale
people came through
we feel the support we appreciate the
support and we'd like to welcome a lot
of new subscribers to the mass community
uh because of the generosity of all that
support we are now in a position with
with mass we're able to
uh make a ten thousand dollar donation
to charity
and that charity uh basically supports
uh food banks throughout the united
states so a lot of good work being done
to reduce hunger around the holiday
season here so thanks so much for your
support um
now
if you missed out on that sale and
you're interested in finding other ways
to support the show or to support the
stronger by science universe of course
you could always go to
bulksupplements.com
and use the discount code sbs pod for a
five percent discount and of course you
could also download the macro factor
diet app just in time for your new
year's resolutions whether you're
gaining uh planning to gain or lose or
maintain weight in a more informed way
uh macro factor should come in handy a
lot of great analytics there
um now along those lines you're probably
going to hear a bunch of fit pros
bashing new year's resolutions uh in the
next like two weeks i'm against that
like you know what it's not that
everyone needs a new year's resolution
but you're gonna hear a lot of the lines
that like oh if you don't care enough to
have started yesterday like you're a
loser and it's not going to work
like that's not an evidence-based
perspective
i always get a kick out of people who
are evidence-based except when they're
just saying stuff they feel like saying
yeah my my other favorite one that
people will throw out there is
there's a statistic that's not real at
all that i see repeated a thousand times
it's like 99 of new year's resolutions
fail
and i think i think the evidence
i didn't look this up before the show
but it's like it's a large number but
not like near universality i think
something in the neighborhood of like 80
of new year's resolutions fail but like
i don't know man one in five is still
kind of a lot yeah i think
when people get
really negative about resolutions
they're i assume that they're kind of
riffing on some research about
temporal landmarks so a lot of people
get more motivated to accomplish a goal
around some kind of temporal landmark in
the calendar whether it's a birthday the
start of a new week the start of a new
month the start of a new year and the
research would indicate that
there's a bit of a fallacy built into
that that's kind of baked into our
psychology sometimes when we set these
temporal landmarks and we couple a goal
with it there's a bit of uh
an illogical assumption the me that
exists in 2022
is completely different and better than
the me that exists now
there's some evidence saying that that
kind of fuels some of these temporally
linked goals and of course simply having
a temporal landmark is not predictive of
successful behavior change so
simply setting a new year's resolution
of course is not
fully sufficient for guaranteeing
success we all intuitively know that but
the temporal landmarks can be a nice
little boost for motivation so if you
couple that with really good
goal-setting strategies
there's no reason that you can't be
successful
with a really nice new year's resolution
so that's a bit of a tangent but
let's get back on track here road to the
stage how's it going greg
uh i mean
it's it's not going i suppose i i think
i mentioned on the last podcast um
my
my goals shifted around the holiday
season between birthday and
thanksgiving and christmas you know a
lot of good food to be consumed around
this time of the year um
and i decided instead of white knuckling
it and continuing to just try to lose
weight through the holiday season uh i
was going to intentionally be at
maintenance for about a month
uh and so yeah we're smack dab in the
middle of that month and uh
pit stops going well i am at maintenance
still below 240 as i intended to be
um
so yeah i i would say that there is a
pit stop on the road to the stage and
the pit stop is uh is it going about the
way i expected it to
good stuff uh how was the road to athens
i'm also at uh unfortunately a bit of a
pit stop
not one that was planned like yours um
you know a couple weeks ago i had a nice
little string of workouts put together
had a a really nice 12 mile run and then
like a 17 mile walk and jog that was on
a trail system with a lot of root
systems and a lot of stuff to avoid
while running
uh then i ran into an injury uh could
have just been the sheer mileage could
have been the uneven surfaces and the
root systems i was trying to navigate
but had a little tweak of my pop lydia's
muscle
uh if you've never heard of that it's
for a reason it's literally useless and
stupid
but the pop lydia's muscle is this
little like triangular shaped muscle in
the back of your knee
that
is stupid as i said and doesn't do
anything particularly important until
you need it and when it starts hurting
then you start to recognize what it
actually does
but anyway i started to notice some of
this pain i'm not certain if it's acute
or chronic in nature could have been an
overused type thing could have been an
acute strain
i was trying to think back did i have
any
particular strides where i landed with
my knee inflection and maybe some
excessive pronation turns out it was
like half the steps i took on that 17
mile journey so i don't know it could
have been one of those steps or it could
have been all the steps i can't really
say for sure but i'm really proud of
myself in this case for
identifying it early and really just
slamming the brakes on instead of
training through it which i typically
would uh i was really stoked about
having the patience to say okay i'm
going to take a couple weeks off do some
other types of training lift weights
once in a while and uh you know i should
be back to running within the next few
days and i think that's going to make
it's going to bring a lot of clarity in
terms of if it was acute or chronic and
if this is going to be something that is
in my rear view mirror or if it will
continue to plague me throughout the
entirety of this process so certainly
hoping for the best there and this was a
great situation where simply being
absurdly busy helps you stay patient
yeah it's like
uh we're around the time of the the
month where you know of course macro
factor stuff is always kind of in full
swing uh and then the the calendar for
mass the research review is kind of done
in chunks throughout the month the last
couple weeks were super busy uh so it
was very easy to have the patience to
say that i'm not going to run today
because even if i wanted to i'm not sure
how i would yeah but okay cool moving on
feats of strength what do you got uh
well first off to wrap up the road to
athens i i and i'm sure all of the
listeners are wishing you a speedy
recovery thank you uh as far as feats of
strength go um
let's see we got
uh
three training lifts and one uh very
impressive competition lift to discuss
so uh
first two training lifts from
uh
i guess i can't really call him a friend
of the show because he's never been on
but a friend of the show in spirit due
to how often he comes up in the feeds of
strength segment
john hack uh recently deadlifted 900 or
like 903
and benched 600 in training for the
first time
i believe he's still planning on
competing at 220. i mean those are
ridiculous lifts regardless of weight
class but
yeah just just blazing new trails
doesn't make sense but uh he is
incredibly strong and kudos to him on
those milestones i do by the way
consider him a friend of the show
because he has mentioned that he has at
least on one occasion listen to the show
so that makes him a friend along with
correct along with everyone that's
currently listening yes um
let's see uh emil lundgren who is a
junior ipf lifter uh he's a 74 kilo
lifter uh and at a body weight of 72
kilos in the gym or 159 pounds he
benched 200 kilos or
441 pounds
and uh he's a he's a teen lifter he's 18
years old makes no [ __ ] sense very
impressive you should check that lift
out
there aren't currently links in the
outlines but i'll i'll get those to you
trex uh so yeah check out the lift very
strong very impressive uh and then
finally the competition lift uh
bulgarian weightlifter carlos nasser
at the ripe young age of 17
broke the senior world record in the 81
kilo men's class he clean and jerked 208
kilos which uh
again
that's a that's an enormous lift for
anyone but uh coming from a teenager
obviously that broke the junior world
record as well
but yeah uh very strong incredibly
impressive and honestly it looked like
he had a little bit more in the tank too
uh the clean looked easy uh the jerk was
never in doubt so um
i mean the the numbers he's putting up
at 17
i i could see him just owning that class
for the next decade plus
good stuff yes sir a lot of strong
people
uh which is always good to see
all right um moving on we've got some
excellent segments prepared for today's
show the first one i'm revisiting a
segment that i i called contextualized
clarifications
and the idea is uh you know adding a
little bit of context to topics that
have been covered previously
particularly when they seem to be uh
potentially being misapplied a little
bit
so the thing i want to talk about today
is reverse dieting
now reverse dieting is not something
that i've ever pushed super hard as a
universal dieting strategy but i've
always left a little bit of wiggle room
for it
in some key scenarios and most commonly
when i've talked about reverse dieting
in the past
it's been in a particular context which
is after a physique focused competition
so you get done with uh you know a
bodybuilding prep for example
you are
shredded hopefully uh so shredded that
your
blood panel indicates you're shredded
right like we're we're talking about
dieting to a point that your doctor
knows you are dieting before they even
see your physique right so we have side
effects related to this dieting because
it is so severe in nature
and when you're at the end of a show you
have some of these symptoms that are
lingering most likely
and you also are in an interesting
situation where you say listen and six
or seven months from now i'm probably
going to be 40 pounds heavier than i am
today and so then the question is
should you try to manage that trajectory
and if so how
and so that's where reverse dieting has
come into play in some of my previous
work i mentioned it in the metabolic
adaptation manual which i'll link in the
show notes um but in that context i was
like i'm not really that fond of super
strict reverse diets
i'm more
in the recovery diet kind of camp
although in the article i talked about
how it's kind of a false dichotomy
really these are just strategies of i'm
about to gain a bunch of weight how
should i thoughtfully manage that
trajectory based on my current
circumstances and my goals for the
future do you want to just real quick
operationally define reverse diet versus
recovery diet absolutely so
like i said uh we're talking about
in this context gaining weight after a
diet so we're talking about weight
regain
and
a popular approach to reverse dieting is
to go
extremely slow with caloric increases so
let's say you get to the end of your
bodybuilding prep you go uh you know
you're you're now a two-time uh two
different sport professional athlete uh
and now you're like okay what do i do
with weight regain and adding some
calories back into my super low calorie
diet
reverse dieting
in its more popular forms is an
extremely slow process of just adding a
little bit of carbohydrate here a little
bit of fat there and meticulously
increasing calories
and in some cases you know i've heard of
people trying to do this in a way that
is almost weight stable where they're
like i wonder if i can stay shredded
forever but just kind of creep my
calories up
and get to a spot where i'm still
shredded but instead of eating 1500
calories a day i'm eating 2 300 calories
a day or 2 600 calories a day so in the
most extreme form we're talking about
these tiny incremental changes in
caloric intake and in some cases people
are
unknowingly or i guess unintentionally
spending a few weeks still in a deficit
and in some cases several weeks still in
a caloric deficit because they're not
increasing their calories quickly enough
so
a reverse diet is like this in most
cases a very extreme process of trying
to meticulously make these very tiny
changes in caloric intake and bumping it
up
so usually there's going to be some
weight gain associated with that but in
many cases it's very minimal weight
gains it's
you know ranging from weight stability
to just a very slow and slight magnitude
of weight gain
reverse or i'm sorry recovery dieting
to my
to the best of my knowledge was
popularized by the the folks over at 3d
muscle journey so like helms and jeff
alberts uh and the whole gang over there
and the idea with
recovery diet i believe it was kind of a
response to reverse dieting and the way
it was being implemented and they're
like dude your competition was five
weeks ago you're still in the deficit
you know or your competition was five
weeks ago and you are still very far
away from the productive phase of your
off season i mean you're not recovering
from your show because you're keeping
your calories so low so the idea as i
understand it with the recovery diet
is that it started out by immediately
making a relatively big jump to make
sure that you were
in
neutral the positive energy balance so
certainly not staying in a deficit
making bigger jumps early on and
facilitating weight regain but doing it
in a controlled manner so instead like i
said in six months i'm going to be 40
pounds heavier that's fine but
that doesn't mean you have to go all 40
pounds the first month and then plateau
for five right you could have a nice
gradual not necessarily linear but
gradual and controlled phase of weight
regain and from my perspective that's
where
that's what recovery diets
aim to do and the idea is that by being
a little more aggressive on the front
end
you can facilitate that recovery so
maybe three months or four months after
the end of your diet your doctor can no
longer tell
based on your blood work that you've
been dieting so hard so the idea is
facilitating that recovery a little bit
more prompt lean a little bit more
proactively so
that sometimes people treat that as a
dichotomy in my article i said maybe not
maybe it's just kind of a spectrum of
approaches that range from
trying to stay weight stable versus
extremely rapid weight regain and what
we need to do is find a trajectory that
basically fits your
your
current circumstances and your goals so
if you get to the end of a diet and you
have no symptoms whatsoever
then
yeah maybe we don't need to be super
aggressive at the beginning right uh you
know there's a lot of contextual factors
to consider or if you're a super elite
physique athlete and you're like yeah if
no matter how i bulk this year there's
no way i'm gaining more than like a
pound of muscle well in that case your
best your best shot at improving show to
show probably has more to do with
managing your leanness throughout the
course of your competitive like calendar
year right so you can set yourself up
for a leaner appearance next season by
being a little bit more focused on
managing that weight regain you know so
there's a lot of contextual factors that
i go into in a lot of detail in that
article but
one of the applications of reverse
dieting shifting back to reverse dieting
exclusively
one of the applications that seems to be
getting more and more popular that i'm
hearing more and more about on social
media
is the idea that
i'm going to use reverse dieting to set
myself up
for a more successful fat loss phase
down the road so before i cut
what i'm going to do is reverse diet and
stay weight stable
but by slowly increasing my calories
i'm basically going to ramp up my
metabolic rate and i'm going to get my
total daily energy expenditure elevated
so that when i begin my fat loss phase
i'm going to be able to diet on higher
calories and that's going to continue to
some extent throughout the diet and it's
going to be way cooler higher calories
more food flexibility less hunger less
hormonal stuff going on
that is the plan that's the idea
and this is not a perspective that i've
ever been super adamant about
reinforcing and the more that i've
looked into it critically
the less
justifiable it appears to be from my
perspective
um and i there was a paper that came out
recently
that i think highlights my skepticism
about this particular application and i
think the best way to frame this
skepticism is by looking at it through
the prism
of
metabolic phenotypes
so briefly
the metabolic phenotypes a lot of times
it's treated as
a dichotomy but it's really kind of a
spectrum where we've got people with
more of a thrifty phenotype and then
we've got other people with more of a
spendthrift phenotype
thrifty individuals generally are
considered
resistant to weight loss so what that
means is in context of over feeding they
tend to quite readily store additional
fat mass and in the context of under
feeding
they tend to resist fat loss through a
number of metabolic adaptations that
i've spent way too much of my life
talking about
someone with a spendthrift phenotype in
contrast is the opposite so they tend to
be relatively resistant to weight gain
in context of overfeeding uh
they simply resist gaining and storing
more fat mass a lot of times their
energy expenditure will ramp up quite a
bit during overfeeding uh this is what
in many cases leads to someone
designating themselves as a hard gainer
this could be a contributing factor
although i think appetite regulation
also has a huge impact on that
um
now someone with a spendthrift phenotype
when they are put into a context of
under feeding
they actually don't have particularly
robust metabolic adaptations to that
under feeding so
they struggle to gain weight
intentionally but when you tell them to
do a fat loss diet
the fat comes off uh as you would
typically expect without a whole lot of
friction so this is the idea of these
phenotypes and a recent paper by
halstein and colleagues
kind of dug into
these these phenotypes and how
individuals with each metabolic
phenotype responded to different
contexts of
under feeding or in this case complete
fasting which is the ultimate
underfeeding or acute overfeeding and
the paper yielded some really
interesting findings i think a lot of
times people
when they think of a thrifty phenotype
being resistant to weight loss
they kind of assume
my metabolic rate my total daily energy
expenditure is just always going to be
lower than someone who spendthrift so
across the board i will have lower
energy expenditure and that's why i am
prone to fat gain and resistant to fat
loss these uh study results did not
reinforce that the relationship between
phenotype metabolic phenotype
and energy expenditure is a little bit
more complicated so the people with a
thrifty phenotype they did have a large
drop in total daily energy expenditure
during over f or during under feeding
however at neutral energy balance when
they compared the thrifty to the
spendthrift individuals the people with
thriftier metabolic phenotypes actually
had higher total daily energy
expenditure at neutral energy balance
and
even with over feeding so the
spendthrift individuals during
overfeeding
the spendthrift people as you would
expect had a larger adaptive increase in
energy expenditure
they are typically more resistant to
intentional weight gain and intentional
fat gain however even with that added
additional uh adaptive increase in total
daily energy expenditure even on
overfeeding
the thrifty individuals had
non-significantly higher total daily
energy expenditure so when we look at
these phenotypes it's not as simple as
these are the people with high energy
expenditure and these are the people
with low energy expenditure it's
how does your energy
expenditure respond to fluctuations in
energy intake and energy availability
relative to your normal level at neutral
energy balance now the reason that i
think this is informative for reverse
dieting is because
reverse dieting is
i would argue for
people who have thriftier metabolic
phenotypes these are the people who say
generally speaking i struggle with fat
loss
i seem to have pretty notable
adaptations to underfeeding that slow my
fat loss down
so
you could think of you know
this idea of reverse dieting to set
yourself up for a fat loss being really
a tool that is for people with a thrifty
phenotype because the people with a
spent through a phenotype
they're fine they're like yeah i start
dieting i lose fat it's all good i don't
need to prime myself for this phase
um
but the big
big problem there
is that when we look at these
individuals with the thriftier
phenotypes who theoretically should
stand to gain the most
from this idea of ramping up your energy
expenditure prior to a dieting phase the
problem is
as we can see in these data their issue
is not having low energy expenditure
before the diet at neutral energy
balance in fact their energy expenditure
is higher than similar people with the
other phenotype
and regardless of how high their energy
expenditure is at neutral energy balance
in this case at the start of that diet
the problem is what happens when energy
goes down when energy intake drops and
they have reduced energy availability
these individuals have an adaptive
response where total daily energy
expenditure
declines and importantly
i have not seen any evidence to suggest
that doing any kind of reverse dieting
strategy beforehand would offset that in
any way there's really no evidence to
suggest that if you're a person with a
thrifty phenotype who experiences
experiences these drops in energy
expenditure during dieting we have no
reason to believe that doing anything to
your energy expenditure at neutral
energy balance or positive energy
balance is going to do something that
you can carry with you through the
dieting phase so
based on you know looking through this
prism of metabolic phenotypes
if you were to say okay who should be
doing this reverse diet prior to a fat
loss phase to make the process easier
and more successful well i look at more
spendthrift individuals and say you
don't really need it and then i look at
thrifty individuals and say i don't
think that there's
anything that we're doing in positive or
neutral energy balance it simply doesn't
seem to change the fact that when you
transition into a state of under feeding
your total daily energy expenditure is
going to drop
to a greater extent than most people so
for those reasons i think one of the
most popular applications of reverse
dieting is uh kind of hard to justify
from a theoretical basis and then from
an empirical basis there's no evidence
to suggest none that i'm aware of that
it actually works so uh i think the
empirical evidence is lacking and i
think the theoretical rationale has some
really big gaps in my opinion yeah um
now i a couple
things that i do want to point out here
is
reverse dieting as an idea might not be
entirely useless there are some
potential applications and i think there
are two that come to mind for me
first of all
like i said earlier if you're a very
advanced physique athlete
and your main opportunity to be better
next year than you were this year is by
coming in leaner at your next show i
think it does make sense to very
strategically navigate the post show
period and navigate that that trajectory
of weight regain you know you're not you
don't need to set yourself up for this
huge off season where you're going to
bulk like crazy and gain 20 pounds
that's not going to happen right so you
don't need to rush the process of
getting back into a really anabolic
state physiologically so i think for
some very advanced physique athletes it
can make sense after a competition i
also think it can make sense not to set
yourself up for your next diet but when
you're tr when you're uh basically
transitioning from the end of your diet
to a long-term maintenance phase and so
i usually i think we're in agreement
that when we talk about someone's
maintenance intake so the calorie level
that allows them to maintain
relatively stable body weight
it appears to be in practice a bit of a
range right so there's not just one
number where it's like if you eat 1900
calories that is the only caloric intake
that can keep you weight stable it
appears that we do have a bit of a range
there's some flexibility there so like i
said if you are uh
let's say a thrifty individual
and you are at the end of a dieting
phase
your total daily energy expenditure when
you're still in a deficit there is
probably suppressed a little bit because
of that thrifty phenotype if you are
transitioning from a weight loss phase
to long-term maintenance and you want to
have more of that dietary flexibility
you want to see if you can get away with
having slightly slightly higher calories
without
significant weight gain
in that context you might be able to
walk your calories up a little bit and
just kind of nudge your maintenance
calorie intake toward the top end of
your maintenance range so basically all
you're doing there is slowly increasing
caloric intake so that you're able to
reverse some of those adaptations that
you experience during the diet and this
is to make your long-term maintenance a
little bit more sustainable
once you get back into your next weight
loss phase like i said i have no reason
to believe that you're not going to have
those adaptive drops again
and another thing to keep in mind is you
don't necessarily have to do this super
slowly
you could just jump straight to a
slightly higher intake and hope that you
know some of those adaptations reverse
themselves but the slower you go and the
more you treat it as an incremental
process the lower the likelihood that
you're going to overshoot the number and
accidentally gain more weight than you
wish than you wanted to right so that's
one instance and then again there's
potential for
uh let's say that you're someone with a
spendthrift phenotype and you're at the
end of a weight loss phase uh and still
you'd like to have a little bit more
wiggle room with your caloric intake
even in that situation there's possib
there's a possibility that you could
nudge your maintenance calories toward
the top end of your maintenance range
because again when spendthrift
individuals start over feeding just a
little bit they often tend to have some
adaptive adjustments that increase their
total daily energy expenditure so all of
that's to say
i wouldn't say that reverse dieting is
completely indefensible in all contexts
i wouldn't say it is unequivocally
useless or unjustifiable however i would
say that one of the more common
applications i see
in my opinion
has a low likelihood of success
and of course if more data come out to
uh contradict that then i'll be in front
of the mic uh letting everybody know but
for now i think uh
i i think the reason i bring this up is
i think it's a bit counterproductive i
think that it has people chasing this
thing that takes them
away from the goal that's at top of mind
they're going through this process that
may not actually be contributing to
success and it can be very disheartening
when you did all that work i mean i've
talked to people who feel like they
mismanaged a diet and they ruined
everything that they gained during that
meticulous reverse diet process that
they went through yeah and i think it's
very discouraging when you put yourself
through that and maybe you do have a
slight increase in total daily energy
expenditure and then you switch to that
fat loss phase and you're right back to
square on square one and i think a lot
of people internalize that as a failure
whereas you know physiologically i think
that's probably a fairly predictable
outcome yeah so
that is reverse dieting and literally
everything i wanted to say about it yeah
i mean i i guess it
it makes sense to me and i don't know
i don't know why
necessarily someone would expect it to
work
otherwise
like in in a different way
just because just because like you know
the the old school approach of bulking
and then cutting and
you know you balk for a while and then
you transition directly into a fat loss
phase
whatever a reverse diet is going to do
for you in terms of increasing daily
energy expenditure um
i i don't know what what that would do
for you that just simply being in a
deficit wouldn't do for you
and so
if you're not in a surplus you mean
yeah yeah that being in a surplus
wouldn't do for you right so you know if
you've been in a surplus for
six months nine months whatever and then
you transition into a deficit and your
calories have to get
relatively low again
i don't know why someone would
anticipate that
uh your experience following a reverse
diet would be different you know like
what
what is what is a reverse diet like you
know basically maintenance we'll call it
an aggressive maintenance like
there's a bit of an oxymoron yeah an
aggressive maintenance a very small
surplus i don't know what that would do
to quote unquote build your metabolic
capacity that
just simply being in a normal surplus
wouldn't and so if people aren't
experiencing
increases in the calories that they can
consume while in a deficit
just following normal surpluses
i don't know why someone would
expect that the calories that they would
be able to consume in a deficit would be
a lot higher following
you know aggressive maintenance or a
very small surplus
i completely agree and that was why i
did want to add that caveat where i
talked about cases where reverse dieting
could make sense and could work uh when
we're when you're talking about shifting
from a diet to long-term maintenance
like you said uh whether you slowly kind
of nudge your calories up there or just
jump to it right away
there's really not much of a reason to
believe that the results would be any
different if you guessed well with where
you jump to
you know the the only real
balancing act there is determining uh
how quickly do you want to get to that
caloric intake and how comfortable are
you with missing by a little bit and
accepting potentially a little bit of
weight gain that you hadn't planned for
but but yeah i mean i i agree with you
and so hopefully
people will
hear this and maybe
reconsider uh or at least feel like they
have more options i think a lot of
people right now feel like dude if
you're not reverse dieting before you're
cut like you're wasting your time what
are you doing uh so i hope that this
alleviates some of that pressure for
some people
okay uh moving on it looks like you've
got a research review here that seems uh
very scandalous depending on what you
conclude so we'll see if i get defensive
uh yeah so um
this
research review i think is
kind of timely but not as timely as it
could have been
around a month or two months ago there
had been
a couple pretty high profile deaths of
competitive professional bodybuilders
and there was a lot of discourse around
like
you know
our or the training methods or the drugs
or whatever in in professional
bodybuilding
um
like particularly dangerous and killing
off bodybuilders at an increased rate
and if if you ask somebody just like in
the world of bodybuilding
to just kind of list you
several bodybuilders who
died of complications often heart issues
um seemingly far too young
they'll probably be able to rattle off a
pretty decent list to you like there
there are a lot of instances that people
are aware of
um
and so i i think there is this growing
perception that
um you know that professional
bodybuilders are just dropping like
flies at a dramatically increased rate
and that the sport is actually
quite dangerous and quite deleterious
from a long-term perspective and so so
to be clear i'm talking about untested
professional bodybuilding here not
talking about natural bodybuilding um
but yeah so so that seems to be a
perception that's forming and like i
said this segment could have been more
timely but
um one i'm not going to name specific
names of people who have died in this
segment because
i don't want to
give the perception that we're you know
trying to use someone's death to
increase traffic to the podcast i i
think that's kind of gross
and two i i wanted to wait to do this
segment uh again just so it wouldn't
seem like we were trying to
jump on something super timely
and just use
deaths in general to generate traffic um
so anyway now that
that
now that the the most heated part of
that discourse is behind us by a couple
months uh i thought i would address this
because i think that that perception is
perhaps incorrect depending on how you
look at it
um so a guy named greg merritt who is
the editor of the website
thebarbell.com reached out to me about
this
a couple months back
and he had an article on his site which
was which was very well done looking at
mortality rates in pro bodybuilders so
what he did is he basically compiled
a list of everyone who had competed at
the most prestigious
untested pro bodybuilding shows so the
mr olympia
the u.s arnold classic
um the
uh precursor to the arnold classic the
world pro
the knight of champions and the
successor to the knight of champions the
new york pro like those are
uh
some of the biggest bodybuilding shows
in the world so he looked to see
everyone who had competed at those shows
going back to the inception of the mr
olympia in 1965
uh identified all of the people who had
competed there and then
basically just tracked down all of the
ones he possibly could
and he was able to confirm
whether or not
478 of those competitors were either
dead or alive and that was 478 out of i
think
570
ish
in total so he he found life or death
records of about 85 of the people who
had competed at those shows
um and and basically just using
actuarial tables uh like likelihood of
death by birth year or by age um
he just plotted the mortality rates of
pro bodybuilders versus just
men in the general american public
uh and he he talks about this like using
u.s actuarial tables um
because you know not every pro
bodybuilder is american but
you know a lot of them are and also just
like
mortality rates differ country by
country and uh part of it's just a
sample size issue like if there are
six professional egyptian bodybuilders
like
you wouldn't really have much of a
sample size comparing that against like
egyptian actuarial table so he just
standardized everything using
u.s data which which i think is is a
pretty justifiable thing to do
and basically found that mortality rates
of bodybuilders uh
were the same as for men in the general
public
and that seemed to hold across
generations so for people born in the
30s uh mortality rates pretty similar
for people born in the 50s mortality
rates pretty similar and the thing that
people are really concerned about now
like uh pro bodybuilders in their 20s or
30s
uh dropping dead
it seems like mortality rates of young
bodybuilders are comparable to mortality
rates of men in the general population
of a similar age so from that
perspective it seems that
bodybuilding
like pro bodybuilding drugs all of that
uh doesn't necessarily seem to be
particularly deleterious at least from a
mortality perspective
however as i mentioned it kind of
depends on how you look at the data um
so like i said this article by greg
merritt was really well done
so he did what i think was a very smart
thing of not just looking at mortality
rates in the general population because
you know you could argue the american
population could potentially be
healthier
and so he looked at data on
pro athletes in other sports to see how
the mortality rates of pro bodybuilders
compare to
other professional athletes uh and so
the mortality rates of pro bodybuilders
actually considerably lower than the
mortality rates of pro wrestlers pro
wrestling
[ __ ] up sport uh not going to expand
on that further but they're
it's uh
it's it's not good like they they put
themselves through a lot
um like a lot of prescription drug
issues uh seems like the the actual like
promotion organizations don't really
look after their talent all that well
uh but yeah pro bodybuilders
way lower mortality rate than pro
wrestlers but also considerably higher
mortality rates than uh current or x and
fl players and current or ex pro
baseball players um so from that
perspective it seems like it may be
somewhat deleterious to a health from a
health perspective because you know you
would anticipate people who are
exercising a lot in generally
maintaining a pretty decent body
composition you would expect them to
have a lower mortality rate than the
general public they don't really seem to
whereas
people like pro football players pro
baseball players do seem to have a
reduced mortality rate
um and i would also note that that's
including pro football players when you
separate separate out linemen versus
non-lineman you start to see some pretty
big discrepancies in health outcomes so
uh that might even be understating uh
you know the the health benefits of
playing football at a healthier body
composition or at a lower
bmi level body fat percentage for sure
so yeah um
so it basically seems like relative to
the amount of exercise they're doing
pro bodybuilders probably do have an
elevated mortality rate but again just
relative to the general public it really
doesn't seem to be that bad
um
the article also looked at causes of
death
which again i thought was a very smart
thing to do in instances where a cause
of death for pro bodybuilders was known
and it seemed like the
causes of death that had been identified
did seem to lean
pretty starkly towards heart disease and
kidney disease relative to the general
population so
even though overall mortality rates were
pretty similar
rates of death from kidney disease and
heart disease were higher than what was
observed in the general population which
i do suspect that is probably related to
uh side effects of steroids and peptide
hormones um
and the other thing to note is there
there's not currently any strong
indication that the relative mortality
rates in pro bodybuilders are increasing
over time like i mentioned um
there is this perception that pro
bodybuilders in their 20s and 30s are
just dropping dead at a massively
elevated rate
and the the data doesn't seem to bear
that out and it could be the case like i
don't
i don't follow the drug world super
closely it could be that there are
new drug protocols coming down the pike
that are super dangerous and 10 years
from now the data could look a lot
different and it may
end up being clear that like yeah what
people are doing now super dangerous a
lot of bodybuilders dropping dead really
young
but currently the the data doesn't bear
that out you're seeing mortality rates
that are comparable to what's observed
in the general population on an
age-matched basis
um
i will note as well so when when he sent
me this article
i read it i found it very interesting
but i i did kind of note in the back of
my mind i was like i feel like i've seen
an article before
saying that pro bodybuilders do have
elevated mortality rates uh i i was not
wrong i found the article that i had in
mind
this will be linked in the show notes
title is rates of mortality are higher
among professional male bodybuilders
pretty straightforward title
lead researcher was gwartney and it was
published in the journal of urology in
2016.
uh and so
you know i i was basically interested
like
what which of these analyses is
more likely actually no um
getting slightly ahead of myself so the
the headline finding of this study by by
guarantee and colleagues
was that uh pro bodybuilders did have an
elevated mortality rate uh relative to
the general male population uh they
found that the relative uh increase in
mortality was about uh 34 percent uh
again compared to
uh age-matched
age-matched men
so that that study did suggest that pro
bodybuilders do have a relatively higher
mortality risk
and so you know i was basically
interested in like
which of these analyses is more likely
to be correct and reliable is it the one
published in the journal of urology or
is it the blog post and honestly
i think it's the blog post and i think
that for one
uh one major major reason
so as i mentioned uh the the article
from greg merritt
um so he identified 571
total bodybuilders that had competed at
those elite bodybuilding shows and he
was able to identify whether 478 of them
were either dead or alive at the at the
point that he was writing the article so
he was he was able to
you know identify
life or death in 85 percent of the
people he looked into
uh and for the guardians study they cast
a slightly wider net to
look at i think
i think they basically just looked for a
list of like all of the bodybuilders who
had won their pro cards since 1948.
um so they initially started
with a list of close to 1600
professional male bodybuilders to look
at 1578
to be precise
but they were only able to find
mortality data for
597 of them
so fewer than 40 percent of the totals
they looked into
and i think that that likely introduces
a pretty
major bias
in in their data because
it's easier to figure out if someone's
dead than if they're alive
because most of the time when people die
there's
you know there's going to be a a
obituary published somewhere like some
someone is probably going to say
something about it somewhere whereas
earlier you you use the term
uh life or death certificates and it i
was like dude i'm like way behind on
submitting all of my life certificates
or life or death death records i think
yeah um so yeah it's not
that hard to figure out if someone's
dead like i'm sure there are people who
die all the time that we would not be
able to find individual records that
they died but but on average
it is somewhat easy to figure out if
someone is dead or not like generally
there's there's information about that
whereas like you know if someone won
their pro card and they're just not
active on the internet but they're still
just kind of like kicking around it's
hard to find confirmation that they're
alive
um and so i kind of think that's what's
going on in the guardians study since
since they were only able to
identify whether about 40 of the people
they were looking into were dead or
alive i think it's it's highly likely
that they
identified
a lot of the deaths and failed to
identify a lot of the people who were
still alive so i think that 34
elevation in mortality risk
in the bodybuilders they looked at i do
suspect that that's
a pretty hefty overestimation
and just simply based on the fact that
the greg merritt article
identified
life or death and 85 of the people they
looked into i i think that that is
probably
more reliable if you ask me
um
so anyway i think the current picture is
complex
uh relative again relative to the amount
of exercise they're doing and
uh like uh bodybuilders tend to have
lower rates of smoking um
generally you don't see super heavy
drinking like you do tend to see a lot
of
uh habits and behaviors that would be
predictive of lower mortality rates
longer life span
and you don't see reductions in
mortality rates relative to the general
population so from that perspective the
drugs they're doing are probably having
a deleterious effect but i do i do think
that maybe
there's some degree of alarmism where
people are overstating the risk
that these people are taking on from
competing in that style of bodybuilding
because it doesn't seem like the
mortality rates they're looking at are
elevated relative to the general
population so
or i mean even if we take the guardney
study uh at face value
a 34 elevation immortality risk like i
don't want to downplay that like that's
not nothing
um
but i mean
the way people talk about it you would
think that they're saying like dude
bodybuilders are like 10 times more
likely to die in their 30s than people
in the general population like that that
seems to be the vibe
of the conversation and even if we take
the 34 elevation at face value which
again i think is probably an
overestimate but even if we did take
that at face value i think that that's
still kind of a more muted story than
than what people are trying to tell
um so yeah i kind of think that that
whole
discussion
is maybe
a little bit too alarmist a little bit
blown out of proportion um
like i do certainly think that there are
risks and side effects of performance
enhancing drugs that people need to
consider i do think that they're that
they are having a
net negative impact on mortality uh but
i think that people are
maybe a little bit too quick
to
exaggerate those effects and
assume that the risks and dangers are
quite a bit larger than they actually
are
yeah but but of course one thing to keep
in mind
is that it is possible for bad things to
happen to you that do not necessarily
kill you correct so of course
uh there are those notable
side effects associated with ped use and
you'll want to make sure that you're
monitoring your health on an
individualized basis if you happen to be
using those types of things yeah and
also to be clear take none of this as a
recommendation i'm not saying drugs are
safe you should do them um
you know i i've mentioned this before
one of the reasons i mean so i mentioned
in this segment uh it it does seem like
there is an elevated risk of
cardiovascular events
that's one of the things that keeps me
off of doing it because dude knuckles
men die of heart attacks in their 50s
and 60s
typically
and uh i don't want to be one of them
or at minimum i i would prefer for it to
be in my 50s or 60s instead of my 40s so
um
you know uh that's like an individual
risk that i'm personally very much not
comfortable with so
yeah i mean
all i'm saying is i think that it's
a much more complex and nuanced story
than drugs bad
and
all of these bodybuilders are dying at a
massively elevated rate like the the
data
the data don't bear out
that incredibly alarmist interpretation
of of the facts yeah
i think one of the things that probably
has uh contributed to that a lot lately
is some of the deaths um
you know back a few months ago like you
mentioned
they were so acute in nature i think one
of the things that does lead to some of
these you know brief periods of time
where we do see elevated deaths or
serious side effects some of those
fluctuations with things that aren't
just like i was on testosterone for a
long time and it was bad for my heart
you know but
like really high doses but you know more
more so things like oh i had an acute
medical emergency because i was using a
particular type of diuretic or other
type of kind of
acute medical emergency secondary to
drug use so i think when you see a few
of those in a row which could be subject
to short-term trends and just what
people seem to be doing those are the
types of things where it becomes so
so alarming uh that it's almost hard to
look at that data
with any level of objectivity right it's
like no dude like
on instagram like four out of six days i
heard about a bodybuilder that died you
know but but yeah um very good work by
you and very good work by what was the
author of that article again greg
merritt a lot of a lot of good greg's
out there in the world very uh very
underrated uh
scientific talent among people with the
first name of greg and i think it is
time
that we rise up and get the uh get the
recognition we deserve i agree so yeah
the uh all the articles that you
mentioned will be linked in the show
notes
uh now shifting gears a little bit uh
it is december correct i think we can
all agree
i think so so
when
the season starts changing uh and when
we go from fall to winter the days get
shorter
and
i have tried something different this
year this is by the way the coaches
corner segment a very practical applied
segment that isn't super super research
heavy
um but anyway transitioning from fall to
winter i tried something a little
different this year i noticed that
generally speaking i tend to be
i tend to be somewhat impacted by you
know what you might consider like
seasonal affective disorder and i don't
want to downplay uh
seasonal affective disorder i don't know
the the severity at which you can say oh
i have that i just know that when the
days get shorter and i have less
exposure to sunlight i i do historically
notice that i'm just a little bit
gloomier you know
mood isn't quite as positive motivation
levels enthusiasm generally just isn't
quite as high this year i tried to do
something about it um so what i've been
doing here i i've tried i've been trying
to lean on
some of the research about uh getting
better sleep some of the research about
just circadian biology in general
and the reason that i'm mentioning this
as a coach's corner segment
is because it's something i've noticed
in my coaching as well i don't know if
you've ever noticed this but sometimes
as the days start getting shorter and
the season starts shifting and people
are kind of cooped up inside a little
bit more and they're not getting as much
exposure to sunlight they're not able to
do the things outside that they normally
like to do
i've noticed some seasonal patterns
just in like the vibes i get from my
clients like the general vibe gets worse
um i've noticed that there's more uh
staleness with regards to training where
it's just like yeah i'm just not as
enthusiastic about these workouts maybe
you're a worse coach in the winter i
considered that the first time i noticed
it i
i honestly did i was like dude
what happened in late november that made
me start sucking as a coach
um but but after seeing it a few years
in a row i was like i think this is kind
of a seasonal thing then you realized
your australian clients were doing great
but um but but i've also noticed even
things like just kind of slightly
heightened sensitivity to discomfort so
like something that would have been like
ah my shoulder is like a two out of ten
on the pain scale
you know
late november it becomes like a three or
a four out of ten
and these are just to be clear
completely non-scientific observations
not evidence-based but simply anecdotal
and me kind of looking at evidence to
think what might be going on here you
know and i know for me personally it was
really just a quality of life thing i
was like
i don't want to be all gloomy for the
rest of this winter so what i've been
trying to do and what i've been having a
lot of success with
uh
first of all just acknowledging that
sleep matters a lot
so i've been trying to do
the really basic sleep hygiene stuff and
be really consistent about it throughout
this season so having a consistent sleep
and wake time uh trying to kind of in
line with circadian biology trying to
align my wake up time
for when the sun is coming up or at
least close to that because
um you know
when the winter comes a lot of times i
get all annoyed that i don't get a lot
of sunlight and i'm like
dude you slept through three hours of
sunlight this morning like you kind of
don't get to complain about
the lack of sunlight so really making
sure i make the most of it and
experience the sunlight that is present
and also getting some sun exposure early
in the day so i've been starting my day
when possible actually getting outside
getting some fresh air moving around a
little bit and getting some of that
direct sun exposure and i think when
people look into uh
some of the circadian biology literature
there's been a lot of emphasis on light
avoidance right so you've probably seen
articles probably heard podcasts
talking about you know good sleep
hygiene before bed uh stay away from
artificial light stay away from light
that's kind of on the blue wavelength uh
part of the spectrum
even sometimes wear blue blockers like
glasses that that block out blue
light
using filters on uh electronic devices
that kind of change uh the the color
spectrum of light coming out so
a lot of focus has been on light
avoidance but there hasn't been much
that i've seen on actual light exposure
and i think it is
most beneficial to leverage both sides
of that coin so trying to get some
really nice light exposure early in the
day
seems to be a really positive thing when
you look at the totality of some of the
research on the convergence of circadian
biology and just overall health and
wellness so i don't want to over hype it
and frame it as like a life-changing
biohack um but
if you're someone like me who notices
that
when the winter comes along and the days
get short you're just a little more
sluggish a little more gloomy and you
know you're interested in maybe taking
steps to be a little bit more proactive
about uh mitigating that or trying to
attenuate it with just little behavioral
things that's been what i've been
focusing on this year
and i've been really happy with how it's
been going so just a nice mixture of
really good sleep hygiene habits a
consistent sleep and wake time and just
trying to get out and get some light
exposure early coupled with uh some of
that blue light avoidance late at night
it's been a really really positive thing
for me and uh also something that's just
practically useful is
being aware that a lot of people do
notice this so like people who might not
think that they have anything related to
seasonal affective disorder it's really
common for people to just be a little
bit gloomier this time of year and it's
important especially if you're a coach
to
uh know that and prepare for that in
your interactions with clients and keep
an eye out for signs that there might be
some
changes in affect that occur seasonally
and just being aware of that can make
you a more effective communicator and
make you more proactive as a coach
especially with how online coaching
works these days you might live in an
area that's you know close to the
equator and you're like dude i didn't
even know that was a problem but you've
got clients at really high latitudes
where i mean they've got a few hours of
sunlight every day and that can be a big
thing when it comes to the subjective
experience of training even health
ramifications aside so uh just a little
tangent there just because
just by doing those little quick things
it's been really uh
really positive for me so so maybe
people will be able to give that a try
and notice some other positive things as
well dude i might have to give some of
that a shot i got to tell you i'm i'm
hit by seasonal affective disorder like
a truck every year i feel [ __ ]
terrible but uh yeah
a lot of people do and i think what it
is the reason i bring it up without
doing like a really science like i don't
claim to be like a circadian biologist
like i'm not gonna get deep into the
weeds of that research but yeah the
reason i thought it was prudent to bring
up is
uh
i didn't even know it was a thing until
i had like seven gloomy winters and then
i was like oh people do that
i thought it was just me and it wasn't
severe enough or large enough in
magnitude for me to say like i got to do
something about this winter stuff
so the reason i bring it up is to
not try to over overstate my knowledge
on the topic but to say hey there are
some little behavioral things that might
actually be
pretty impactful
makes sense to me okay what's our next
segment here uh oh we've got a q a yeah
we got some q and a's do you want to go
first or should i
uh yeah we can we can trade off a little
bit i reckon okay uh why don't you start
with your first one sure so um
there were there were two questions in
the facebook group uh about
uh optimizing biomechanics from gavin
chester and ross quigley
so gavin asked how important is quote
unquote optimizing biomechanics for
hypertrophy for example adjusting line
of resistance with direction of the
muscle fibers etc
we're also chimed in i second this i see
a lot of instagram accounts that go into
detail on both lines of resistance
strength slash resistance curves active
range of motion for a given muscle etc
and basically like how important is that
stuff do you need to be concerned about
it
um
and uh yeah so
my perspective is that
it's hard it's hard to know so so this
is a
uh partially scientific answer and
partially just my opinion and vibes
based answer
and the reason it's hard to give a son a
fully scientific answer to this
is that uh a lot of the ideas that that
people are putting forth are
not directly tested so like you know for
example if you say a
particular type of way of doing cable
rows is going to build your rhomboids
way more than some standard way of doing
maybe like uh
inclined bench dumbbell rows like
your your
it's your prerogative to make that claim
uh but that hasn't been researched so
you know could be correct could be
incorrect um but it's hard to
objectively say
so
you know we we are
mostly in the realm of opinion and
conjecture here but my perspective is
that it's probably a matter of degree
um and for example the principle itself
of of different exercises or different
variations of exercises
maybe being more or less effective for
hypertrophy in general or hypertrophy of
a particular region of a muscle
that general idea does have some
scientific support so again not support
for specific individual exercises but
just kind of the concept itself so for
example there's um
there's one study showing that incline
bench builds the upper pecs better than
flat bench we've talked about that on
the podcast before i'm a little bit
skeptical of that study but just noting
that that it exists um
there's a recent study showing
that uh knee extensions build the rectus
femoris way better than uh like squats
do so you know you can't necessarily
assume that all quad exercises will
build all heads of the quads equally uh
there's a study showing that bench press
and triceps build like different heads
or a bench press and tricep extensions
build different heads of the triceps so
for example
uh bench press seem to be really good
for specifically building the lateral
head of the tricep uh whereas the long
head of the tricep was grown a lot more
effectively with like skull crushers
so there's there's direct evidence on
that
and then just regional muscle activation
in response to different exercises and
regional muscle hypertrophy are are
pretty well established phenomena at
this point so just kind of on a baseline
level there is
there is reason to believe that um
you know attempting to to quote-unquote
optimize exercises for a particular like
to target particular muscles
might have some merit even if there's
not direct evidence for
the specific exercises or exercise
variations being discussed
and there's also some research showing
that relatively small uh quote unquote
optimizations can have a notable effect
effect on hypertrophy so it's not just a
matter of say bench press versus tricep
extensions for different heads of the
triceps even relatively small variations
of the same general exercise may be more
or less effective so there was a study
by
mayo
i believe from this past year
looking at hypertrophy of the hamstrings
following seated or lying hamstring
curls finding that seated hamstring
curls were
quite a bit more effective for
hypertrophy
probably because they
they were training the hamstrings at a
longer muscle length so if you're seated
you're in some hip flexion that
lengthens the hamstrings might make
seated leg curls a little bit more
effective for hamstring growth than
lying leg curl so there there even is
some evidence
that uh the relatively small quote
unquote optimizations like that could be
effective
personally
i i do think that
the most important factors
are just
range of motion so for example can you
load the target muscle at relatively
long muscle lengths like near the end of
its range of motion
and also just whether the exercise
you're doing
is likely to be limited by the muscle
you're the most interested in so
you know for example um
take dumbbell bench versus bench press
some people's bench press performance
might be limited by their triceps or by
their shoulders and for them maybe the
bench press might not be the most
effective
uh
peck builder but
with dumbbell press for example for
virtually everyone that's going to be
limited by their pecs so
you know that would probably tend to
make it
an effective pec exercise for most
people um so i think those are the two
biggest factors just range of motion and
whether or not the target muscle is
going to be the limiting muscle for
uh the exercise being performed and the
other caveat i'd throw in is that i
think for biarticular muscles there's
some decent evidence to suggest that
single joint exercises tend to be more
effective than multi-joint exercises so
i mentioned tricep extensions versus
bench press for
growth of the long head of the triceps
tricep extensions were more effective
long head of the tricep is a multi-joint
muscle
and same thing with knee extensions for
rectus femoris growth again
the rectus femoris is a biarticular
muscle single joint exercise seemed to
be better
so you know i think that those are the
main factors to keep in mind whether or
not
optimizations passed to that point make
much of a difference
i'm kind of agnostic on
um
and uh i i think that
i i think that in general a way to
approach it is
just kind of to ask yourself whether you
[Music]
need something fresh for a particular
muscle or not so you know for example if
you've got pretty big pecs and you feel
most
kind of standard pec exercises in your
pecs they feel pretty pumped pretty
fatigued after you do some pack training
i don't think you need to go out seeking
crazy new pec exercises like you
certainly could just if you
want something new to do for novelty's
sake but i personally don't think it's
going to affect your your results all
that much however if there is a
particular muscle group where
like just the the standard go-to
exercises don't really seem to be doing
it for you so
i i think like lats are a pretty common
one a lot of people don't feel their
lats as much as they would like to if
they if they were doing
pull-ups pull-downs pull-overs just kind
of like standard lat exercises
and and maybe they have
relatively poor lat development compared
to the rest of their physique
if you come across someone on instagram
or some other platform saying like here
are some crazy new lat exercises that
that will really blow up your lats and
help you feel your lats contract and
doing what you want them to uh if pull
downs aren't getting the job done for
you
i mean my perspective is it it doesn't
hurt to give it a shot um
you know if what you're current
currently doing isn't working uh
at minimum it doesn't hurt to try out a
new idea i do think that a lot of the
kind of
i think that a lot of the reasoning
underpinning a lot of the exercises be
that that might be recommended kind of
under the umbrella or for the purpose of
like quote unquote optimizing exercise
technique i i do think that the the
reasoning
some might be a little bit flimsy at
times and it kind of reminds me a little
bit of like keto content
so
they they both kind of go with like
here's a plausible sounding mechanism i
tried this thing and it seemed to work
for me uh and therefore we can
generalize it and and it's a good thing
for everyone so in the case of keto like
hey
like insulin is this thing and like oh
that's that seems scary and like i tried
a low carb diet
help me control my appetite and lose
weight therefore like low carb keto is
the best everyone should do it and i i
get kind of the same vibe
from the kind of like galaxy brain like
exercise variation stuff like oh man if
you like do do rows on this exact
machine in this exact way like it
technically lines up with like the
the line of pull for this region of your
lats a little bit better and like i
tried it and i got i got a pretty good
pump off of it so like
everyone should do it this way this is
this is way better than the typical way
of doing this exercise
i don't know to to me it seems like it
it seems like some of that content makes
some jumps that are somewhat
unjustifiable
and at minimum
makes claims with more
with a with a higher level of confidence
than is fully justifiable like you know
here's a plausible mechanism and it
seemed to feel good for me uh
i i don't think is enough evidence to
therefore
recommend it as a generally superior
thing for everyone um
so yeah i
some of it leaves a bad taste in my
mouth but i i think i have a
um
i think i have a generally
sympathetic perspective to it um like i
said i think
most of the time the old standards get
the job done for most people but i also
think it doesn't hurt to have more tools
in the toolbox if there are
some muscle groups that say
just just aren't aren't going well for
you like the stand the the old classic
exercises don't really seem to be doing
what you want them to do or if you're a
coach and you train clients and like you
know
for a particular client they just for
whatever reason
feel
uh like rdls in their glutes and they
feel leg curls in their [ __ ] calves
because your gastroc is also
technically a knee flexor and like man
this client just can't grow their
hamstrings like what do i do you know i
don't think it hurts to consume some of
that content because if someone has a
galaxy brain idea for a novel hamstring
exercise it doesn't hurt to know it
exists to try it out with a client who
might be struggling to feel their
hamstrings working with with kind of
classic hamstring exercises so
i'm sympathetic to it overall but i do
think a lot of that content
um
kind of like
overstates what
the the reasoning and evidence that
backs it up but
like i said i i would say i'm
vaguely sympathetic towards it
have you come across any great exercises
to really light up your pop lydias
because i could use some of those if you
have any i have not although i will say
uh here here's kind of a
weird looking but
uh
like
galaxy brain like quote unquote like
optimized version of an exercise that i
thought looked ridiculous
before i tried it and now absolutely
love
and also this uh this exercise comes
from like one of only three t-nation
articles that i regularly share with
people so uh john meadows
had a really good t nation article back
in the day i maybe it may have been like
2011 2012 like it was
it was quite a bit in the past
but it was on shoulder training
and uh one of the things i had always
noticed is like
i never felt my rear delts doing
anything like if i just did kind of like
normal rear delt raises
they'd get they'd get a little bit of a
pump but like i'd mostly feel it in my
rhomboids and mid traps um
and i didn't have particularly good rear
delt growth which was actually a problem
for me as a power lifter because i had
no shelf for low bar squatting uh and
like i wanted i wanted to try low bar
high bar seemed to be fine but i had
zero rear delt development so uh like i
could do singles for low bar squats but
if i tried to do reps the bar would
start sliding uh and so i come i come
across this t nation article uh by by
john meadows who i liked and respected
uh seemed seemed to be putting out good
content and so uh the rear delt exercise
he recommended
was you basically just take
way heavier dumbbells than you could
possibly do full range of motion with
and you're basically face down on a
bench and doing like super partial range
of motion rear delt raises um
and you know you're intentionally trying
to relax your scapulae and not like
retract on every rep and so you're just
doing like little swings that you're
only using your rear delts for uh and
then you're also trying to like make
sure the dumbbells don't hit at the
bottom so like there is still some
eccentric component where you're using
your rear delts to decelerate the
dumbbell so they don't claim together at
the bottom of every rep
and i gotta say man i love them they're
great that's the only rear delt exercise
that really blows up my rear delts they
they're [ __ ] toasted at the end
they're the only things that make my
rear delts sore and i got some some very
solid rear delt growth out of them uh
they finally gave me that shelf to where
i could uh
rest the bar pretty comfortably for low
bar squats
so yeah i'm
i'm sympathetic to the idea i just think
that that sometimes people over play
their hands um
and
you know i see it less personally i see
it less of like here are more optimized
versions of exercises that are going to
work way better for people i see it more
of like i had a creative idea for how
you could target this muscle and if you
struggle to target this muscle uh here
here's an idea to try out like that
that's how i personally uh
interact with with content like that um
so yeah you can you can view it however
you please
good stuff i'm going to answer a few q a
questions here kind of quickly
first i got a series of questions by
someone named fantastic elevator six
um and you have to really watch me when
i say some of these usernames because if
it's a completely inappropriate
reference i'm not gonna get it so you
have to come in and say hey we uh we we
don't support whatever eric just said so
uh anyway
the series of questions was about my
recent transition to a vegetarian diet
um
and
i got i got a kick out of the the series
of questions uh they were they were
partially facetious but
um
i think that there's too much
attention
dedicated to the idea that a vegetarian
diet is like
wholly unsustainable and not compatible
with human life like like so um for
example like uh
how is it incorporating all those beans
and legumes into the diet like it's fine
uh questions like you know
how has been like you know my gi system
dealing with all the additional plant
food uh
totally fine like no difference at all
question any change in supplementation
to uh to complement my dietary change
not really
i was already taking a multivitamin
and the only real change i made with
supplementation was instead of taking
fish oil i switched over to algae oil
which i actually much prefer greg we
were talking about this the other day
fish oil is known to have that kind of
fishy
smell to it sometimes and you know
sometimes you'll get the it's kind of
gross but the burps with the fishy
aftertaste that stuff grosses me out
with algae you feel like you're just
eating some delicious seaweed
it's really really nice so i actually
even if i were not a vegetarian i
would probably always go algae oil over
fish oil if given the chance
um
the uh and if like i said i'm not like
uh
being dismissive of this series of
questions because they are good
questions um but yeah like people have
asked me is it hard to get protein in
honestly not really unless you're on a
really low calorie diet or your protein
is
realistically higher than you need you
know a lot of people are like dude i
can't do a vegetarian diet i could never
get the protein and it's like right but
why are you having like four grams per
kilogram of protein you know yeah um but
yeah so it really hasn't been that bad
there have been you know minor
inconveniences minor uh you know
situations where i have to think about
okay where am i going to get a
plant-based source of protein but
overall it's been a very easy change and
i haven't had to do anything too crazy
in terms of supplementation or anything
like that but the part of the question
that i thought was excellent uh
i would like an update on how the moral
superiority feels um is the
lack of cognitive dissonance making your
thinking clearer and his lack of b12
killing all your gains so a excellent
string of questions um
wait where were people actually asking
that yeah it was it was in it it's a
facetious list of questions here about
going vegetarian um
one of the things that's funny is i did
run into like a major issue of cognitive
dis
i ran into a moral conundrum so
my girlfriend's cat is
uh
needed a switch in food and we're trying
to figure out uh they stopped selling
her old food and she's allergic to a lot
of the common foods and we're trying to
figure out what kind of food to get from
my girlfriend's cat
and uh
dude they made me sad like they're just
like she's like should we get this food
made of rabbits and i'm like dude no not
not the little rabbits and then like
yeah we went through this whole list of
animals and finally settled on a
salmon-based food for the cat based on
which animal did we feel less sad about
about eating yeah um
because you know
the cat is a lovely cat but uh
unfortunately an obligate carnivore yeah
so the cat will be eating meat and so
yeah we still buy these food products
made of animals but fortunately we were
able to avoid uh the bunny food that was
that was a little bit over the line for
me
but uh anyway yeah so
it's been good and it's not not that bad
uh question here about creatine moving
on
from uh
an alpha betty white is a username
uh
would removing creatine before and or
during a water cut be advisable
how big of a strength loss should i
expect and in what time frame
assuming that i'm a responder to
creatine
so i would not bother removing creatine
in the context of a water cut
first of all to do it you'd have to do
it ahead of time so the washout period
some people say four weeks some people
say you know closer to six or eight
weeks depending on how confident you
want to be but we're talking about a
month or two of going without creatine
to get it fully washed out from your
system and so like when you're reviewing
a study on creatine uh if there's a
washout period it better be at least
four to eight weeks otherwise there's
going to be some residual uh elevations
of creatine stored in muscle and other
tissues um so i don't know if it's
really worth it to like if you're
someone who actually gets benefits from
creatine and you're a responder i'm not
sure that you want to go you know
two maybe even three months without the
creatine leading up to an event where i
assume you're hoping to optimize your
performance and another thing to keep in
mind
is that you can still very much
dehydrate yourself when you're on
creatine so the creatine will increase
your kind of baseline total body water
level but that doesn't mean that you're
going to be unable to then reduce body
water like you can absolutely dehydrate
yourself to your heart's content despite
the fact that you're on creatine
your heart may or may not be contented
with it exactly so once once it's
pumping
blood through your [ __ ] arteries that
looks like molasses yes um
you can dehydrate to your heart's
discontent
regardless of creatine supplementation
and i will say my bias here is that i'm
just generally not very fond of water
cuts if i'm being honest
of course i understand there are certain
there are certain situations where you
accept the health related trade-offs
for the performance-related benefits i
do think that there are many athletic
endeavors where people think they're
getting a performance benefit from their
water cut but they're actually harming
their performance depending on the
timing of the cut and the timing between
weigh-in and actual competition but
that's probably a conversation for
another day but uh no i i don't think
there's much utility in removing
creatine uh before a water cut
depending on the situation if i were
coaching you i'd probably maybe try to
talk you out of the water cut especially
if it's a very aggressive or extreme one
but nonetheless the creatine is not
going to be a critically important
factor there
another question here
and then i'll kick it over to you
question here from magic the dude chef
um
some foods have a decent amount of
protein by the numbers but you know they
have a very low quality protein such as
collagen
when tracking macros how should we
account for this low quality protein
you know that's a good question um
and collagen is honestly
a terrible protein uh if you're looking
at it from a muscle protein synthesis
perspective uh
most uh
quality scores for it are literally zero
because it has a complete and utter lack
of tryptophan so like if you were just
going to look isolated a dose of
collagen for promoting muscle protein
synthesis it's a rubbish protein however
within the context of a whole day of
intake and a whole bunch of different
protein sources and in most cases some
very high quality protein sources that
have an abundance of tryptophan
slipping in a little bit of low quality
protein here and there uh is not
necessarily that bad whether it's a
little bit of collagen here and there uh
some of the lower quality plant-based
proteins so like soy is a very high
quality protein from plant but you know
you start looking down the list at some
of the lower quality ones and you start
to really
think like i don't know this amino acid
profile is pretty weak but
overall i say my general inclination is
to count it as protein and just to make
sure that your total daily protein
intake is adequate you know relative to
your goals and to make sure that you
have a good mixture of proteins in your
diet so
i don't necessarily see a problem with
counting as you know fairly low quality
protein toward your daily total as long
as it's not making up a huge proportion
of your total daily intake um you know
so for example
tying this back into the idea of
vegetarian and vegan diets you know you
can take two low to moderate quality
proteins that have complementary amino
acid profiles put them together and end
up in a really good spot in terms of
muscle protein synthesis so i i don't
like to promote the idea of really
micromanaging amino acid profiles but of
course looking at your diet in its
totality
you want to make sure that you have
enough protein and you want to make sure
that you don't have glaring weaknesses
with regards to any particular essential
amino acids so if you're getting you
know 60 of your daily protein from
collagen that sucks that that's a bad
plan but i don't know if it makes sense
to have this kind of dueling count going
on throughout the day where you're
counting this subtotal of high quality
proteins and this sub
subtotal of low quality proteins and
things like that so i'd still count it
toward your your total daily protein but
i would encourage you to try to make
sure that you either have a diet that is
rich in high quality proteins or
rich in proteins that are complementary
in nature when it comes to their amino
acid profile i i can tell you exactly i
mean my
uh experience with with using collagen
protein yeah basically exactly what
you're describing so i um
i started using uh
just like gelatin powder in my meal prep
maybe like two or three months ago um
so one of the things that happens to me
when i'm in a calorie deficit is just
like i get joint aches all the time
i don't know why but like they say yeah
if you lose weight your joints will feel
better i gotta i gotta say one of the
reasons why uh
especially when i'm training hard i tend
to want to be in a moderate to sometimes
quite aggressive surplus is that [ __ ]
makes my joints feel good and like you
take calories away and like my hips ache
my knees ache now that i [ __ ] broke
my arm earlier this year my wrist and my
elbow ache those are new um
and so uh
i i saw some of the um
the research that's been published on
collagen synthesis with like collagen or
or gelatin supplementation uh and just
thought like you know what it can't it
can't hurt it can't hurt like i'll give
it a shot uh just just throw some
gelatin powder in my meal prep uh i
mostly eat like rice based dishes like
rice and lean protein um so like yeah
i'll just throw some collagen in make
sure it dissolves uh might help if
nothing else uh might improve the mouth
feel like make it taste a little bit
more like luscious and luxurious um and
so i just put like 100 grams of gelatin
powder in like in with the water when
the rice is about to cook
and subjectively one it seems to have
been helping my joints they feel better
don't know if the two are related not an
rct don't necessarily take it as advice
but my personal experience pretty
positive um
second in terms of just like how i
account for it it's basically what
you're describing so
uh
my most recent meal prep which i did
last night big old batch of congee a lot
of pork um and like 117 grams of
collagen and so the the whole kit and
caboodle has like 740 grams of protein
in total and each serving of it will
probably give me about 55 grams of
protein give or take um
and of that like three quarters of it
probably is from the pork and then
there's enough rice that like a
non-trivial amount of it is from the
rice a little bit from some mushrooms
and then uh about a seventh of the total
protein in what i'm consuming comes from
the collagen i added so of those 55
grams of protein probably like
around 40 or slightly under is is coming
from animal protein and
from there i i figure like ah i'm set
for the meal and then uh maybe some
slightly lower quality uh plant proteins
um
and then
you know of of the 55 grams probably
eight of them are coming from the
collagen
and like
i don't know it's probably not as
i think i'm consuming enough protein
that having slightly lower like 55 grams
per meal is
more than sufficient
and so if i replaced those seven eight
grams of of gelatin with more pork or
chicken or whatever i don't know that
i'd really get anything out of it and uh
i mean like you said i just don't want
to micromanage my [ __ ] so
um
with with the addition of that like i
kept my daily protein targets the same
so the amount of quote unquote high
quality protein i'm eating per day has
probably decreased by
12 grams maybe
yeah and like i'm fine with that i
subjectively it doesn't really seem to
to be making
a difference in terms of like muscle
retention uh
and then subjectively joints seem to
feel pretty good so
i don't know seems okay
yeah and i think another thing that
contributes to this
because i get this type of question a
lot
something that contributes to it is i
think a lot of people make
dichotomies in their head about protein
sources they're either
a high quality animal based
protein source or a low quality
plant-based protein source and they kind
of just
look at a protein source and say it's
either high quality or low quality
should i count the low quality but
realistically it's a continuous spectrum
and some of your animal sources for
protein are not as high quality as your
other animal sources and there are some
very high quality plant sources and some
very low quality plant sources and so
what i kind of think about in my head is
like you hold up this list of protein
quality scores and say
draw me the line where it doesn't count
anymore uh
very very hard to do that it's our
favorite dichotomizing continuous
variables right but it's best it's very
hard to draw your line
and especially when you consider the
fact that
you take a low quality protein and a low
quality protein with complementary
profiles
and all of a sudden you're you're
looking pretty good yeah so yeah going
source by source can be very difficult
but i do
encourage people to look at their diet
in its entirety and like greg said make
sure that your collagen is not
you're not doing collagen instead of
chicken right or instead of pork or
whatever whatever the meal was it's uh
collagen
along with you know some of your higher
quality sources the other thing i note
as well is just uh
um
a practice that i've heard from several
people like engaging in recently is
just the idea of
you know when it comes to counting your
your protein for the day kind of
sticking with uh like research based
protein targets like shooting for 1.6
grams per kilo or whatever it is 1.6 1.8
um but then as far as counting your
protein goes only counting the high
quality protein sources so
you know i'm going to make sure that i'm
getting 1.6 1.8 grams per kilo of
protein per day
but i'm only going to count like the
eggs and chicken and milk or if you're
vegetarian the soy maybe the mico
protein and everything else just
basically not counting it towards your
protein targets for the day
a point that
that i always mention when i see that
is the um
like the protein the research derived
protein recommendations that exist
exist in the context generally of mixed
diets right so
you know if they're saying that like uh
somewhere in the neighborhood of a gram
per pound or like 1.8 grams per kilo
like somewhere in that general vicinity
uh the research saying that like ah
that's probably enough to maximize
hypertrophy or muscle retention in a
deficit and maybe slightly higher for
that but whatever like all of those
targets
are based on studies where people are
eating mixed diets like in those studies
they're not exclusively counting high
quality proteins and so like that's the
context that those
uh that those recommendations
are derived from and so if you're basing
your targets on
1.8 grams per kilo of only high quality
protein there's probably nothing
necessarily bad with that
but if you're doing that because your
dietary targets are being informed by
the research your protein
if you want to make an apples-to-apples
comparison between your diet and the
research that you're basing it on you
are consuming higher protein levels uh
than
you know is is necessarily being
recommended and that you are using as
your targets and and again i don't think
there's anything wrong with eating
slightly higher levels of protein but
if you wanted to go about counting using
that method
you could probably justify slightly
lower protein targets just because some
protein is going to come along for the
ride and virtually everything you eat so
if
that is just the way that you prefer to
count a slightly lower daily protein
target maybe if you're an omnivore like
to 1.4 1.5 grams per kilo would probably
be more justifiable like if you are only
counting the high quality protein you
probably don't need to shoot for quite
1.8 grams per kilo just because like
that that's not how the research was
done that those uh that those
recommendations were derived from and
just for context i
wish i had the type of memory where i
could give exact numbers but
um
there is a nice paper i saw the other
day that looked at
you know in a typical diet in this
region what percentage of protein comes
from plants and what percent comes from
animal sources it's very likely that
when you look at the studies that we're
getting protein recommendations from
like you said the individuals are eating
mixed diets with a mixture of higher and
lower quality protein sources
probably like 40
depending on the region of that protein
is coming from plants that tend to have
lower quality scores so like you said i
think a lot of times we assume oh i need
to make sure i'm getting 1.6 grams per
kilogram of the high quality stuff to
match this literature when in reality
it's very much not matching that
literature
all right so i think i've answered all
the ones i'm going to answer because we
are at about a hour 45 give or take here
but uh the floor is yours to answer as
many of your remaining questions as
you'd like i i've just got two more one
should be pretty short the other might
be a little bit longer so starting with
the short one
from gerald scott
he asks what are your personal and
professional opinions on designated
bouts of low intensity steady state
cardio at a certain percentage of
maximal heart rate versus step counts do
you think there would be a significant
difference that the low-intensity
steady-state cardio would be superior
for fat loss
and and i think um
i think the best way to answer this
question is probably practically rather
than scientifically for a couple reasons
one
you know there's there's a body of
literature on step counts and there's a
body of literature on cardio but there
aren't that many just like direct
head-to-head comparisons of step count
based interventions versus cardio
interventions like there are some but
i don't know i don't want to build an
argument off of like three papers um
and so i think the the best way to
answer this question is is just
practically um
and for me personally i i jin i tend to
favor step counts um
but i i think that it largely
i think that it largely just depends on
the needs and preferences of the
individual so the first thing you need
to to consider is the question of
feasibility so
for example if someone works a pretty
sedentary job and maybe they're only
getting in three four thousand steps per
day like they're quite sedentary um but
their step counts are that low because
they're really busy like they they have
a sedentary job but like they work a
full-time job a lot of family
responsibilities a lot of stuff they
need to do when they get home in the
evening and
you know you prescribe to them like ah
try to get 12 000 steps per day um
yeah you know there may just not be room
in their schedule for them to squirrel
away an hour and a half worth of walks
through
through like various
open chunks of time in their day like
that that may not exist and so for them
to comply with your recommendations uh
they might have to make some pretty big
sacrifices maybe even like reduce how
much they're sleeping which might not be
the best thing um versus like for that
individual if you just prescribe them
cardio you said like hey do
uh 30 minutes of steady state cardio um
you know at whatever pace is manageable
for you like you know should be pretty
challenging but you shouldn't be dead at
the end of it uh and do that four days
per week that might be a much more
feasible intervention they could just
get up in the morning get it done and
then go about their otherwise busy life
so you know i
i don't particularly care in theory
which one of those would produce better
results because
the the cardio prescription is probably
just going to fit in with their
lifestyle better and be more feasible so
feasibility is something to consider
another thing to consider since this
question was asked in the context of fat
loss
is what someone's hunger satiety
response is to
uh like a step count based
recommendation or a cardio based
recommendation
one of the things that i think people
uh anticipate when it comes to exercise
and appetite and satiety is that
um
basically that there's kind of like a
one-to-one
compensatory relationship between
calories burned in exercise and then how
hungry you become and that's not
necessarily the case so
depending on the individual and the type
of exercise they're doing and the
context and a bunch of other [ __ ] uh the
appetite response to a particular type
of exercise or a particular way that you
increase calorie expenditure can go a
bunch of different directions so
um
like exercise can be orexigenic it can
make you hungrier and want to eat more
or it can be anorexigenic it can
decrease hunger and and just kind of
like
uh without necessarily even thinking
about it reduce calorie intake
and can i uh
just reinforce your your concept of how
variable it is historically i've always
been like
oh dude cardio makes you so hungry very
bad
but in hindsight i'd only tried doing
cardio when i was like late in prep
but in a different context when i you
know uh ventured out onto the road to
athens i've noticed that my appetite is
actually a little bit lower and that i
you know there's research to indicate
that within certain uh
circumstances a little bit of aerobic
activity can kind of re-couple your
satiety signals to your your energy
needs yeah uh and so
yeah i feel like a dumb ass because i
never considered the fact that i'd only
been doing cardio in one particular
context
and even within an individual i've
noticed those those uh sources of
variability well yeah and so that that's
another important consideration as well
like um
like baseline levels of activity so you
you mentioned uh like coupling uh hunger
responses with with energy expenditure
and then uh we've talked about this on
the podcast before but in general
one of the reasons that having a
sedentary lifestyle can
promote weight gain
is that when people are
reasonably active like you know we're
not talking elite endurance athletes but
just you move around some you have a not
completely sedentary lifestyle there are
various compensatory mechanisms that
tend to couple
uh energy intake with energy expenditure
um
and there there's kind of like a range
where
as you expend more calories like your
hunger tends to scale pretty much
linearly with it um but then like yeah
if you're
like super sedentary you can have
elevated um like hunger cues in excess
of of the calories you're burning and so
it becomes uncoupled and you tend to
gain weight over time and so if you are
very sedentary uh it's not incredibly
uncommon for an increase in
activity or exercise to decrease
sensations of hunger or
uh to have really no effect and so
you're increasing caloric expenditure
but not really having much of an impact
on hunger and satiety so anyway there's
a lot of
there's a lot of considerations another
major one is just kind of like how
someone
um like perceives the exercise they're
doing
so there's been a bit of research on
this
where if someone uh expends calories
doing some form of exercise and they
view it as kind of like a chore and
unpleasant and they don't like to do it
uh their compensatory eating afterwards
uh
tends to be quite high versus if it's
just like oh
i i like going for a jog i went for a
jog it was fun there doesn't seem to be
that much compensatory like excess food
intake afterwards um so yeah it's not
even just pure physiology it's also a
matter of of how someone interacts with
the exercise they're doing and how they
perceive it uh all of which is to say
um like you can
you can generate kind of like
uh average recommendations for different
types of exercise and their their impact
on hunger and satiety so
something people will often mention
is that a potential benefit of high
intensity interval training is it does
actually tend to blunt appetite and and
reduce hunger post exercise
but
you know that that is something that is
true on average but is also incredibly
variable person to person so
um
yeah when you're deciding like am i
going to tell someone to do cardio or am
i going to tell them to get in more
steps may not be a bad idea to try both
and just just see how the person
responds to it um
like it's very plausible that they could
do some cardio and say man i hated that
and now i'm going to treat myself with
whatever and you know they they end up
uh with a net uh caloric surplus
in spite of the fact that they just
expended more calories
um or they could view it as like oh that
was great and now i feel like fresh and
energized and ready for the day and like
don't feel the need to compensate for
that uh and same thing could go with
like a step count intervention like
i i personally find that that tends to
blunt my appetite like if i'm getting
more steps in i just tend to find myself
less hungry but i also really like the
walks i go on
i just throw a podcast on enjoy the
nature and you know
it's nice i think it's good it's to me a
pleasant thing
um but if it's the type of thing where
it was very challenging to work into my
schedule and i just didn't like doing it
um
you know i could see myself perceiving
it as more of a chore and
you know then like maybe wanting to
treat myself with some food as a way to
say like good job for going on that walk
greg so
you know
it's gonna vary a lot person to person
um
and so yeah
in general i i think that uh
recommending people up their step counts
is
on average more productive um but i i
definitely don't think that it's what i
would recommend for all people in all
circumstances so you know
just like try it out and gather both
objective and subjective feedback from
your clients like
um
how is this making you feel do you feel
energized afterwards do you feel wiped
out
are you having an easier harder time
sticking with your diet following this
form of exercise uh and and use that
information to make your decision
so that was supposed to be the short one
so let's uh
let's dive into the final question of
the day
uh nicole bazemore justin collins and
arabella murray
all wanted um
our take but they're going to get my
take on
a recent study that was published
and an npr article about it so the study
in the npr article will both
be linked in the show notes the title of
this for the record by the way uh i've
already weighed in on this topic but i
keep all of my perspectives behind a
paywall so you got to subscribe to mass
if you want my take on artificial
sweeteners all right
uh anyway so the title of the study in
question uh published i think last month
or in october
was obesity and sex related associations
with differential effects of sucralose
versus sucrose on appetite and reward
processing colon a randomized control
trial and i gotta say
most of the time when a when a study
gets a lot of headlines and a lot of
press it tends to have a very
uh simple and audacious title so kudos
to these researchers for getting an npr
spot for this paper because that's a
convoluted title um
but anyway so
what this study did is there were three
conditions um so subjects consumed water
a sucralose sweetened beverage sucralose
is the generic associated with the brand
named splenda
and a sucrose sweetened beverage so
sucrose is table sugar
and it was a crossover study so all of
the subjects completed the same testing
after consuming water after consuming a
sucralose sweetened beverage and after
consuming a sucrose sweetened beverage
with a washout period between each one
and
i'll note most of the outcomes in this
study were related to brain imaging and
i'm not going to even touch on those
because that's not
even even within spitting distance of my
area of expertise um
yeah i don't know the first thing about
fmri i understand in general what it's
measuring but uh you know i'm i'm not a
i'm not a neurology expert i can't claim
to uh
be able to interpret those outcomes with
any meaningful expertise so i'm just
gonna let them be
i
uh did one very mri heavy study
as a grad student but would you even
believe that i was not the mri expert on
the team interesting yeah so
unfortunately i also cannot comment yes
but
what i am good at is arithmetic and uh
knowing dude you're you're as good when
numbers are bigger or smaller i was
gonna say you're as good at addition and
subtraction as virtually any of my peers
i'll take it
um
so yeah they uh they they basically gave
people these three beverages and and
look to see
like how they impact different reward
centers of the brain and whatnot uh but
also on a much more practical level
two hours after they consumed these
beverages uh they consumed an ad libitum
meal with kind of a buffet style
eating uh setup so you know people could
get a bunch of different foods and just
eat as much of them as they felt like
they wanted to eat
um and they were looking at the impact
following water sucralose or sucrose
ingestion on food intake
and so uh they did find
that on average
comparing the sucrose and sucralose
conditions that subjects at the ad
libido meal did consume more calories
following the sucralose condition than
the sucrose condition
so that
is consistent potentially with the idea
that artificial sweeteners might
increase food cravings or like the the
sweetness doesn't come with calories and
so
it's not as satisfying as it could be
and then that might make people want to
eat more at a subsequent meal
and they also found that there was a sex
effect so when they stratified it by sex
they found
that relative to the sucrose condition
the male subjects didn't eat more
following the sucralose beverage but the
female subjects did they ate about 100
calories on average more
um following a sucralose sweetened
beverage than a sucrose sweetened
beverage so that's again seems
consistent with the idea that ah maybe
maybe artificial sweeteners are no good
maybe it increases appetite or food
cravings or whatever
but as i mentioned the devil is in the
details here and the piece of
information that i haven't shared with
you yet is the sucrose sweetened
beverage contained about 300 calories
and so
in total combining the calories consumed
in the beverage and the calories
consumed in the subsequent meal the male
subjects consumed about 300 fewer
calories uh in the sucralose condition
than the sucrose condition and the
female subjects consumed about 200 total
fewer calories again counting both the
meal and the beverage um
so with that context uh in total the
sucralose condition did actually result
in a relatively lower total energy
intake
um compared to the sugar compared to the
sugar
um and so like
i don't know to me i i care about that
maybe more than uh
uh brain imaging research
like you know if if people are given the
opportunity to eat everything they want
to eat and they're still consuming
overall fewer calories following
artificial artificially sweetened
beverages than sugar sweetened beverages
that still seems to suggest to me that
um
at minimum the artificial sweeteners are
fine when it comes to
promoting overall energy intake
and
sounds like you're gonna say something
well i was just gonna say you could
argue that this is evidence of kind of
the ideal use case for a artificially
sweetened beverage where it's like oh
for the totality of this meal if you
swap this beverage it will still taste
nice but your total calories will be
lower yeah so that's pretty good i agree
uh and to be clear the beverage wasn't
consumed with the meal it was consumed
but two hours prior but yeah i i agree
conceptually uh so anyway i
don't find the results of this study to
be particularly scary or to suggest
that the artificial sweeteners
you know enhance appetite or cravings to
a degree that would likely be
deleterious
and i'll note that that is also in
keeping with a
meta-analysis that was published last
year by laviata molina and colleagues
title was effects of non-nutritive
sweeteners on body weight and bmi in
diverse clinical contexts systematic
review and meta-analysis that will also
be linked in the show notes
but it's straightforward they just
looked for all of the rcts that ran for
at least four weeks that compared a
non-nutritive sweetener which um
i tend to just call artificial
sweeteners uh not all of them are
artificial sugar alcohols aren't
artificial but whatever it's what people
would often refer to as artificial
sweeteners uh so it compared uh studies
lasting at least four weeks
comparing non-nutritive sweeteners
versus
either sugar sweetened beverages or
water
as as a
control condition and it found that uh
kind of in all of the studies pooled
together non-nutritive sweeteners
led to
negative effects on body weight and i
mean that negative in a numeric sense
so either less weight gain or greater
weight loss
then when they broke it down further
just for example just looking at the
studies comparing it against sucrose
versus studies comparing non-nutritive
sweeteners against water they found that
the effect of water and non-nutritive
sweeteners or not beverages sweetened
with non-nutritive sweeteners they had
similar effects on body weight so
water did not have superior effects uh
in other words but neither did
non-nutritive sweeteners and then
compared against sucrose non-nutritive
sweeteners did lead to a numerically
negative impact on on body weight and
bmi um and then they also looked at the
type of dietary intervention so
in uh restricted intervention so like
when people were put on a diet that was
intentionally reduced calorie for the
purpose of of losing weight
um
it didn't really seem to matter what
sort of beverages they consumed like
non-nutritive sweeteners did not
enhance weight loss in those studies but
they also didn't have a negative impact
on weight loss in those studies but then
in studies with uncontrolled diets they
did have a significant uh
numerically negative impact on body
weight and bmi so
you know um
again i care less about brain imaging
than a meta-analysis that's actually
looking at changes in body weight and
bmi over time and in that context
non-nutritive sweeteners seem to be
neutral to positive if you're
interpreting
either greater weight loss or
less weight gain as as a positive
effect
the one thing that i will note uh just
as as a caveat and
i wouldn't say potential calls for
concern but just kind of a thing to look
out for potentially
um is you know there are a bunch of
non-nutritive sweeteners or artificial
sweeteners out there
so the the study i started
talking about
initially for this segment
looked at sucralose again brand name
there splenda
but most of the research in this area
looks at aspartame and then there are
also various sugar alcohols
a couple of studies look at saccharin
and honestly i don't even call saccharin
an artificial sweetener it's not sweet
like i don't care what people say
saccharin's not sweet it just tastes
like [ __ ] uh same thing with stevia
stevie is not an artificial sweetener
it's an artificial bitterer uh like i
i've seen
here
okay here here's what i think they call
that one a non-artificial bitterer yeah
whatever i don't care so this is um
the thing that i think i get the most
heated about when it comes to like
diet culture and people trying to make
like healthy desserts and whatnot
like
because there there's the
the high protein dessert
community and the people with
undiagnosed orthorexia community is a
circle
i believe and so there's a lot of kind
of like health halo stuff around like oh
natural is good stevia it's natural it's
not it's not like aspartame it's not
like sucralose so like yeah make these
little [ __ ] protein balls and use
three cups of stevia and like it's gonna
be sweet and it's gonna be great and
then like you know people will be like
oh man like uh it's not quite as good as
the real thing but i still like it
you're lying to yourselves no one likes
stevia stevia tastes terrible uh
if you want
i don't generally do plugs if i'm not
getting paid i'm not sponsored by
splenda but honestly the next time you
make one of those [ __ ] recipes sub
out the stevia for splenda or just like
a store brand of sucralose i promise you
it's going to taste so much better
stevia is terrible and uh
if you if you don't agree with me you're
lying to yourself and i i will not hear
arguments to the contrary
anyway getting back on topic uh yeah
there are a lot of
sweeteners that kind of fall under the
umbrella of non-nutritive sweeteners and
what i'll note is the meta-analysis i
just talked about looking at weight in
bmi
um
i don't i don't have the numbers
directly in front of me but if memory
serves like 80 percent of the studies
were aspartame studies like aspartame is
far and away the most
well-studied non-nutritive sweetener and
i believe that only one of the studies
in that meta-analysis did look at
sucralose so
it would be fallacious to necessarily
assume that the impact of all
non-nutritive sweeteners on
hunger or appetite or weight or bmi are
all identical
i'm not arguing that so it is possible
that the impact of sucralose on weight
and bmi over time
might differ from the effects of
aspartame um
but
you know so so
that is a door that's still open
but the uh the the study that the npr
article was about that that uh i was
asked about on facebook
it's not sufficient
for me to become scared of sucralose or
to think that it it would have a
negative impact on uh on weight over
time
yeah and and by the way the same is true
a lot of times people ask about how
non-nutritive sweeteners impact the gut
microbiome that's another area of
research where there are many studies on
it
not a ton but there are several but
again it's very aspartame dominated
you know we definitely need more
research looking at
some of the other popular non-nutritive
sweeteners but this study
and this is not um
to be critical of the original
researchers because they had a very
practical component to their study
um but one of the things that
that i get a kick out of is when you
have conversations usually on the
internet
and
someone will be using mechanistic data
to make conclusions about an applied
outcome
when we absolutely definitely do have
applied research on the topic you know
like
i saw a thread the other day where
someone was like oh dude carbs are so
bad and i was like how do you know that
and they're like
look at this study from five decades ago
when they infused insulin
i'm like dude these people didn't even
eat a carb yeah like what do you what
are you going on about
but yeah it's the same kind of thing
where like sometimes i'll look at these
extrapolations of
mechanisms that often tend to lean in
the scary direction and i'm like
dude you know we know what happens when
people eat that right like
yeah it's uh and that's not to say that
mechanistic uh data is not informative
or helpful or important but like
if we have actually seen what humans do
in a very specific context and that's
what your question is about
it's okay to also use some of that data
too one of uh
an instance of that that i
previously found very funny and i don't
say i don't say previously because i no
longer find it funny but i say
previously because i don't see people
making this exact claim anymore but
whatever i'm gonna put some people on
blast in the past uh
so
it used to be maybe like five or six
years ago people would use um
acute muscle protein synthesis research
to make
very firm arguments about training
frequency and i i personally did this a
little bit as well
not to
an extreme degree but i'm i'm slightly
putting uh a past version of myself on
blast so consider this uh a slight
contextual clarification uh for me as
well
but anyway um
so yeah you look at uh you look at
research looking at protein synthesis
following resistance training
in trained lifters and oftentimes you
will only see elevations in muscle
protein synthesis uh after a resistance
training bout lasting
12 hours or 24 hours
and from that i didn't make claims quite
this extreme but i i did see this exact
claim like look
as far as training frequency goes if
you're only hitting a muscle once per
week you're building muscle one day per
week and you're losing muscle six days
per week
you will
at best tread water but there's really
no way
to build muscle with a training
frequency of just once per week it has
to be at least two or three times per
week but
honestly
every day is probably best because
because these elevations are like maybe
24 hours tops
and it's like brother there's
there's a lot of research here like
oh
a lot i would say a
at the time probably a majority of the
longitudinal resistance training studies
used a per muscle training frequency of
once per week these days i think the
average is is closer to twice per week
in the research but
back then man most of the research on
resistance training you were looking at
per muscle frequencies of once per week
and it's like
they're growing man they're getting
they're getting bigger uh
so yeah it's like extrapolating acute
results to
uh long-term assumptions that
are fully contradicted by an enormous
amount of research uh
even at the time when i was very much on
the high frequency train i was like
some of y'all need to cool your jets
like you you can't
you can't go that far with it yeah
all right i think it's time to play us
out and again this is one of those
instances where i'm gonna plug something
and unfortunately they don't sponsor the
show but
if this company ever sponsored the show
[Laughter]
you'd never see us again because we'd be
rolling in it
uh huge shout out to big pharma in
general and the good people at
glaxosmithkline
uh people have been reaching out to me
uh lately after the podcast goes up and
say like eric listen
you sound like [ __ ]
uh you're not well
i worry about you and i wish the podcast
was more enjoyable to listen to because
your voice is terrible
and so basically i'd been congested for
a very long time and i kind of convinced
myself that that was just how the rest
of my life was going to be
um
and i actually took a medication and
would you even believe it worked i used
flonase that's not a medical
recommendation but
i used it and like it has honestly
changed my life
uh dude i used to have to sleep with my
mouth wide open so i could breathe i
probably had like sleep apnea of a
particular kind just not like the actual
reason for it but i couldn't breathe at
night yeah uh and
yeah so basically uh i took a medication
that was supposed to do a particular
thing it did that exact thing and i'm
crazy i'm blown away as as a stubborn
old man that doesn't go to the doctor or
use medical treatments it kind of
reminded me that medicine in some cases
when used responsibly
could actually work which is pretty
incredible so
uh
if you can hear the difference in my
voice it's because modern medicine
actually works so huge shout out to my
dear friends in big pharma
uh okay i think that does it for
this particular episode as always uh
thank you for listening and we will be
back soon